wir haben wirklich alle sachen die in
clash of plants dies in gleicher platz
zu bauen gibt ja meine lieben villiger
paradies und herzlich willkommen zu
einem minecraft clash of plants das ist
keine modifikation ich suche schon seit
wochen nach irgend so ein clash of
kleines modifikation aber ich habe
einfach mal drei coole maps die clash of
plants karten oder clash of plants
aufbau systeme leute die das in
minecraft nachgebaut haben habe ich mir
einfach mal raus gesucht und wollte euch
einfach mal zeigen
ich habe natürlich nicht links auch in
die beschreibung gepackt und ich bin
wirklich schon wenn ihr irgendwie einen
clash of plants mod oder so ich würde
das unglaublich einmal vorstellen weil
ich selber das spiel sehr sehr gerne
spiele gibt bitten daumen hoch wenig
allgemeinen videobotschaft platz machen
soll
also wie ich quasi mit myphone ich habe
jetzt möglichkeit gefunden sich das mit
einer besseren grafik aufnehmen kann
das mit myphone aufnehmen meiner kleinen
welt und ich bin jetzt mittlerweile
level 53 oder irgendwie so um den dreh
ich weiß ihr seid alle viel besser aber
gibt man daumen hoch und ich glaube bei
weiß nicht wir können einfach mal sagen
also ich möchte und so ein video auf
einem kanal machen aber wenn ihr
irgendwie weiß nicht 5000 daumen hoch
knackt oder so dann kann ich dass er
eventuell mal machen und aber das eine
ganz andere sache ich mit sagen wir
gucken sie erst mal die erste map an und
zwar weil ich euch hat einfach drei
karten zeigen die sehr sehr cool kleins
nachgebaut sind und zwar ist es die
karte von fällt die wahl findet ihr
links in der beschreibung bekannt dass
ganzen angucken hier ist bauen wir das
ist quasi dieses mittelding ich weiß
nicht wie es hingekriegt hat ihm die
fliegt man auf dieser karte relativ
schnell das ist dieses hauptgebäude was
man zerstören muss damit man quasi den
ersten stern sozusagen bekommt wenn man
dann sind hier allerdings raum architekt
hat am coolsten sieht man das ganze man
sieht es in clash of planes ja immer von
hier so in etwa und schaut man sich das
ganze mal so an
also sieht das ganze halt aus wir haben
hier beispielsweise die werfer wir haben
das lager ich glaube dass dort ein lager
darstellen
ja das ist das elixier lager das sieht
man an diesem in diesem an dieser lila
wolle dann haben wir hier ein goldlager
das sieht man daran diesen komischen
teil und dass gold drin ist wir haben
hier relativ viele sachen das ist glaube
ich dieser schubst room wo diese leute
drauf stehen diese bogenschützen die da
die leute abschießt und so diese relativ
viele coole sachen dass es eine bombe
die sie da auch sehr sehr geil aus also
mit diesem totenkopf denen das
darstellen soll es auch sehr cool
ich glaube das ist ein das soll einen
dunkles elixir wo war da stelle ich mir
nicht so ganz sicher es ist auf jeden
fall richtig cool das ist auch so
dargestellt wird ok kommen hier das ist
so quasi immer dieses wenn man einen
blog setzt den kleinst halt so dass
rings herum wenn man diese person
angreift die dieses wie man wenn man im
blog setzt sich fort wenn man ein
konstrukt setzt kann man halt ringsherum
erst hier wieder wenn man diesen diese
person angesagt erzählt wieder diese
sachen dass er gleich an halt alles wenn
die 5000 jobs also das ist auf jeden
fall die märkte nummer eins sehr cooles
was ist das denn ist das einfach so eine
goldmine das aber auch geil dass es je
so runter geht und so was alles richtig
irgendwie läuft diese map haben hier
auch extrem flüssig ich weiß nicht woran
es liegt aber ich hab's ja schon oft
gesagt ich habe in der 1.8 mal richtige
frame einbrüche und probleme aber wenn
ich hier zur um kokettiert bei mir hier
läuft alles flüssig irgendwie und dass
die 1.7 15 und ab der 1.8 habe ich total
die frame einbrüche
ich würde sagen er kommt zur 2
kommen wir zur nächsten map ich bin mir
grad gar nicht sicher von wem das ganze
gebaut wurde es ist auf jeden fall noch
nicht komplett fertig ich habe ich den
link aber auf jeden fall in die
beschreibung gepackt das dritte teil des
dritte wir das q cells will ich auf
jeden fall noch abwarten
aber hier sieht man halt viel viel
cooler dass das ganze relativ klein
gehalten ist und wirklich noch so eine
anfang stadt ist klar schon erklärt
klaus plant den clash of clients wir
haben bei der ersten map gesehen der typ
hatte schon gold mauern okay was heißt
schon ich habe schon lily maor aber wir
sehen hier das die ganzen gebäude noch
in der ersten stufe sind es gibt noch
alles ein bisschen schöner aus ja auch
mit dem gras und so genutzt übrigens das
dandelion täglich bekomme bald auch ein
eigenes texture pack gemacht von dem
jetlag pixel wolf der macht er für mich
ein sehr cooles
und ja das ist aber eine andere
geschichte jedenfalls ist dass sie
wirklich wie so ein kleines game
aufgebaut wir sehen hier beispielsweise
klasse level 3 cache layer phy switches
for only a member blabla die nations
also er möchte das ganze wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal so als game an bieten wir
ihnen auch hier sachen zum beispiel für
die sex times flusses israeli defense
treff puls update on hold -rating gold
also man könnte das ganze eventuell mal
spielen oder das sind halt einfach seine
statistiken
ich hoffe mal dass sowas ganze
irgendwann auf dem server existiert also
wenn ihr da irgendwas wisst dann
schreibt es auf jeden fall den
kommentare das eventuell auch andere
leute davon profitieren von eurem wissen
quasi und ja wir können euch einfach mal
gucken dass das ist weiß ich gleich ob
sie zum schmiedl da oben drauf so eine
eichel
man hat gar nicht sicher weil ich das
ganze halt damals richtig viel gespielt
haben vor einer woche wieder runter
geladen habe und deswegen diese ganzen
gebäude hat sich halt vor einem jahr
und das ist glaube ich so eine normale
bauhütte oder er das ist eine bilder
builders hat also diese bauhütten hab
ich glaube ich drei von schreib mir mal
eure sachen welches level ihr seid ihr
werden eventuell und so was alles das
sieht nach dem elixier dingsbums aus
dass hier auch die anordnung habe ich
aber nie genommen so dass ich die teile
aber das ist auch egal das zeige ich
euch dann wenn 5000 werk schafft ist
eine goldmine
wir können die hälfte also das lesen
wirklich so auf einzelheiten geachtet
beispielsweise dass es hier dann so in
die gänge runter geht und so was alles
also das ist sehr sehr sehr sehr cool
das ist auf jeden fall die map nummer
zwei will ich sagen auch props an dich
denn das gebaut hat hat er steinmauern
aber das ganze ist ein bisschen familia
gehalten und sehr sehr auf die
kleinigkeiten geachtet also überall
findet die irgendwelche über
irgendwelche kleinen schilder die euch
irgendwie sagen wird das ist und alles
mögliche ist sehr sehr cool von oben
sieht das ganze so ausdrücklich gerade
noch ein bisschen von oben sieht das
ganze so aus da haben wir jetzt endlich
das elixier lager und da hinten ist gold
lag erst gar nicht entdeckt
von oben sieht das ganze sieht schon
viel mehr aussieht eine kleine sache
blabla und ich würde sagen das ist auf
jeden fall die zweite map das ist keine
reihenfolge das ist jetzt nicht das neue
top 5 microsoft den top drei top 3 clash
of flames haben bekommen jetzt zur
ersten
sache was keinen sinn also zu verletzten
wir machen einfach recht und zwar ist
das ganze auf einem server und zwar
steht die ip beziehungsweise das video
über diesem server näher beschreiben das
ist von euch einfach die spieler sagen
ein 1 1 ck nat da haben wir dann ein mrt
und einen cookie will kann einfach den
emerald rechts klicken dann dort das im
moment den wir können hier wird wir
können ja auch teleports klicken und
dann zu clash of cultures of clients und
dann sehen wir hier das hier sachen
gebaut werden also wir haben hier zum
beispiel alle möglichen gebäude
aufstehen also wir haben hier die lager
dass das dunkle elixir lager dann haben
wir hier für als normale elixir die
werden auch hier immer größer und so
dann haben wir hier die normalen
goldlager also die man ganz am anfang
hatte
man kann das ja immer mehr aufwerten im
laufe des spiels und das für es hat sich
alles in die richtung da hinten
wir haben hier das elixier teilen und
ist halt auch alles mit liebe zum detail
also beispielsweise das wirklich oben
dran noch mal so ein kleiner pineapple
drauf ist dann einfach zeigen soll okay
da ist die sache an der das ganze daraus
schüttelt wir haben hier die goldlager
wir haben wirklich alle sachen die in
clash of plants dies ungleich aufzubauen
gibt finden wir quasi hier wieder und
das nicht nur für klettern auch zum boom
beach das ist dieser neue typ ist
übrigens auch gerade auf dem server 11
das ist dieses neue teil dass wir das
hier sind die lager wo man die leute
rekrutieren kann also wir können hier
nicht noch jahre weiter fliegen hier
sind unendlich viele sachen schon gebaut
die irgendwann mal also er hat sogar
eine serie auf seinem youtube kanal wo
er das ganze hier bord und wo wir zeigt
mir das ganze gemacht hat was jedes
einzelne von diesen teilen bedeutet
diese lx hier
bohrer oder alex goldlager elixier lager
dunkles elixir lager alle möglichen
sachen die hier ist hier quasi gezeigt
wird oder diese town hall oder ist es
schon die townhall wie man hat gar nicht
sicher ist auch egal jedenfalls alle
möglichen sachen die ihr hier quasi
schon gebaut hat könnt ihr auf seinem
kanal verfolgen und ich würde sagen das
war es dann auch mit dem kleines video
ich wollte ja aber so ein paar
fortschritte hier zeigen die also ein
paar leute da ich mittlerweile machen um
minecraft mich für so was echt mal
verziehen kann man könnte schon fast
eine game app vorstellungen der ja auch
schon lange nicht mehr gemacht hat
nämlich einfach so oder einfach noch
minecraft leshop weil ich einfach alles
gezeigt habe irgendwie und das werdet
ihr das jedenfalls sehen hier sind auf
jeden fall richtig richtig coole sachen
service n11u kate und ihr findet die
ganzen links in der beschreibung wenn es
euch gefallen hat und die eventuell ein
kleines video von mir wollte in dem im
echten clash of clients auf dem handy
dann zeigt dass wir mit einem mag ich
bei 5.000 welches machen oder will ich
sagen ich muss jetzt gibt es drei
mitkomme aufnehmen und wir sehen uns
dann in einem weiteren video irgendwann
mal wieder oder einer skulptur geblieben
villiger paradies